i've seen the article that for every 10
democratic professor there's only one
conservative i know all that data that's
a monopoly that's not a small monopoly
that's a monopoly when i was at harvard
at an opm program
with all these entrepreneurs and the
debate of hillary and trump was taking
place
i watched them screaming every time
hillary said anything
and i watched them boo and these were
professors at harvard
that has 40 billion dollars in their
endowment i
saw how much they hated it wasn't they
were against trump they
hated trump or anything that had to do
with capitalism i'm not talking about
this side
what i'm asking you is the following
here's what i'm asking you because
again i'm gonna i'm planning on being in
the marketplace and competing for a long
time as long as a man
upstairs keeps me healthy healthy i want
to compete i got three kids that i want
to compete as well
i'm asking you the difference between
capitalism
socialism and communism yeah
look what's called socialism i mean
bernie sanders
uh of course he's lying says denmark is
his
socialist country the prime minister of
denmark said denmark
is not socialist so we have that problem
but let's take the skin in avian
countries and say that's socialism
actually uh there was something like
85 or 90 of their economy is
capitalist communism is this one
it's a one-party system there's all you
have to toe the party
line the party line is in this country
is already called political
correctness you cannot disagree with the
left without being denounced as a racist
which is a crime in their minds
and being suppressed their economic
programs are you won't have hey you said
what did you say 33
taxes they're going to tax 90
100 trillion dollars where does it end
and it means government ownership of
everything
this is not scandinavian socialism
this is marxist communism they're as
communist as fidel castro of us who
by the way when i was a young man i i
fell for his uh you know his
his party line hook line and sinker
he was a new leftist he was neither a
communist nor a capital whatever the
hell he's sitting
he was they lie now um
we have already in this country
the foundations of a totalitarian state
and
and why do i say totalitarian
if you if you listen to any of the these
leftists
every aspect of your life is something
they think is political
people are losing their jobs for a woman
lost her life
this 24 year old mother was murdered
for saying all lives matter this is what
we're up against
it's not the the joe biden time servers
it's the ideologues that are the problem
now
we have 47 states in the in our country
that have hate crime legislation
a hate crime is a thought crime
you kill somebody that's a crime
there anybody who kills another human
being is deranged in some way
their motives their intentions but
making it a hate crime
makes it a thought crime i give you an
example one of the first implementations
of
hate crime legislation was three black
kids
went to see the movie mississippi
burning in wisconsin
they came out they were really angry
from what they had seen
and there was a white kid across the
street and one of the three
said let's go f that white kid up
and his two friends or
chard started going across the street
and he said no no i didn't mean it
literally and they beat the crap out of
this kid and hospitalized him
now all three were charged with the
crime of beating him up
and the guy who said let's go f
up got an extra two years for the hate
crime
when you have a hate crime
of course it's that hate speech also
you have the foundation of outlawing
anything that you disagree with and
you can see them use it in practice they
call
trump a white supremacist for 30 years
donald trump was a major public figure
everybody in america knew who donald
trump was
but nobody said donald trump white
supremacists
until he ran against the democrats now
why do they call him a white supremacist
because the democrats have a dirty
secret that they're trying to hide and
defend
from from the public and that is that
they control
every inner city of size in america 100
and have for 50 to 100 years
every injustice in the interst every
killing field
chicago detroit baltimore st louis
100 controlled by the democrat party and
has been for 50 to 100 years
every injustice done to blacks real and
imagined in the inner city
democrats are a hundred percent
responsible for there's not a republican
in sight in minneapolis
you know or chicago
[Music]